at eight thousand four hundred fifty
meters we found a climber whose oxygen
was running out then we gave our oxygen
to him so he's straight away he's alive
we started risking him down then we got
another climber he also ran out of his
oxygen so we gave our oxygen so we are
off oxygen now conducting the rescue
from 8
450 meters without oxygen when you are
not climatized it's a suicidal mission
but we knew what our body was capable of
all this rescue stuff in affirming it
comes because i want to sleep peacefully
when i go to bed brother and i don't
want to say that okay
i left this in know fellow climbers
behind when i had the ability to
do the rescue
nims bloody perjurer how are you my
brother
i'm good chris and so you know glad to
be here
you know talking with you in your
podcast and all you keeping well
i'm very well man i'm in the
fifth location that i've recorded in out
in dubai so for everybody that's
watching this is yet another backdrop
that you need to get used to
thankfully the internet is significantly
better here and you're in
is that your garden i'm in kathmandu
brother you know
so yeah i'm staying in this you know
hotel park blaze
they're like family to me and uh yeah
there's some here quarantined so
it looks beautiful man it looks
beautiful yeah
let's get into it you were six years
away from a full pension
from the special forces and then you
leave to climb
14 of the highest mountains on earth why
wow spot on buddy so
for me everything what i do in life it
needs to have a purpose
and i started climbing you know
first when i was 29 years old and that
kind of started leading into
into the project which was to climb all
the 14
highest mountain of the world which is
above 8000 meters
we call that as a destined peak and
there are only 14 of those
and the fastest someone had climbed this
was in nearly eight years you know 14
days short eight years
and uh i felt like i could do this in
you know within seven months um
and why why i left all my you know like
job security pins and and everything it
was purely because
i felt like i had a bigger purpose and
um
honestly if it was money for money i
would have never been able to achieve
this kind of you know
uh goal or project if it was for
the selfishness or it was just for our
family or you know all this love
affections
and all those bubbles that we live in
again i wouldn't be even close to
achieve this kind of
mission but what i had purely believed
in was
i really wanted to show the world that
you know what human body is capable of
and for those who don't understand you
know the peak in a high altitude
mountaineering in a thin year and all
that
just to put things into perspective what
i was saying at that point was
okay if the world record for you know
the full medicine
is two hours i'm gonna do that in 10
minutes
that was the equivalent of this project
that's why
everybody was laughing at me at that
point you know
nobody would believe in this no
sponsorship came in through
but then again you know i had a cool
reason why i was doing it
i just told you one and the second one
was the nepalese climbers
you know have been the frontier of a
thousand meter peak and you know when
you
you hear the story they always say oh
yeah they all just carry you know big
loads and that is strong
and all that not really you know we are
much more bigger than that we have our
own decision-making capability we all
can guide
we all are super technical members as
well
and i felt like the the justice needs to
be done there so i wanted to raise the
name of the nepalese climbers in an
international platform which was very
close to me um
so that's the second reason and the
third as well
was you know i truly believe
the house that i live is not my home i
believe in earth is our home because
you know that's where you're most alive
you know
you don't if you listen just to give an
example very tiny example
if you stay in your home if you've got a
bigger problem whatever it is
your home doesn't kind of you know like
relieve you it doesn't give you the
thrive it doesn't give you excitement it
doesn't give you
adventure but then earth is a bigger
home where let's say for example even
though you're super
stressed you got any problem if you go
for just like hill walking
or a walk by the river or by the nature
or in the glacier you're super happy
so our our actual home is earth and i
felt like
with the experience that i had seen i
really believe that
i need to raise the awareness about
climate change and global warming
and those three were the main pillars
why i did why i did
so and i i truly believe on those you
know purpose
uh and and that's why this mission came
and for that of course as i said
i had to sacrifice my job i had to give
up my pension
my mom and dad were really upset at the
start my brother didn't spoke to me for
like
three months and there wasn't a full
financial gains i had to remortgage my
house
and there was not even still sponsorship
every day i was
i was working so hard and i have never
been stressed out in my life and i will
tell you this example
i was driving in a motorway and every
day i would go to like london to meet
four or five people do the sale speech
and
and come back home but everywhere i go
they were like oh it's not
possible and then if you think you are
that good why we haven't heard your name
before
and i used to say okay i came from
special forces background and we
have to be covered so even though i had
this all world records i had saved
people's life nobody knew about
it and all this craziness brother and i
i remember that night when everybody was
saying no and and this is impossible i
was driving in a motorway and i had like
tears coming through through my eyes i
stopped i had to obviously debrief
myself and then i cracked on and
this is all was for the bigger purpose
and i felt like
i have i have somehow you know achieved
you know those purposes and and then
those reasons why i wanted to do this uh
this mission
so yeah it's it's loads of story over
there brother
that's beautiful man what do you want
people to take away
from what you did you said that you
wanted to prove
human capability what are the lessons
that you want the general public to take
away people who aren't going to climb
everest who aren't going to try and do
this
psychopathic endurance events
every moment when i was in the mountain
chris you know
when i felt like i was gonna die i said
name's not today
not today and uh i really felt like my
story should come out
because i know for a fact it's gonna
change so many people's life i know that
because it has
it has changed my life for example if
you look at who is
cypress he was underprivileged in a
kid who was born in nepal he even had
flip flops i used to
live in in the house in this room where
like the chicken
farming was on top of us from there you
know i wanted to join the gurkhas
then i didn't even made it on the first
attempt
even though i was the fastest man i was
the fittest guy
there was vacancy for 25 people out of
2000 candidates who came out there
only 18 past the physical test and i was
amongst those 18
but just because the the guy who was
accessing didn't like me
he kicked me out i had the rights to get
that vacancy that
passed because there was 25 passes and i
was just aiming
amongst 18 people who passed this test
but then i didn't give up i went second
time again and i eventually made it
then even from the gayakas to going into
special forces
the gurkhas had served in the british
military for 200 years
and none of them had ever made it into a
special boat service
so for me at that point when i heard
about sbs uk special forces it was like
oh man this is like james boney stuff
you know they are so cool and you got to
be so
good at this you got to be this they got
them with that you got to be
super fit super smart all these things
and when i said i wanted to be part of
that group
again my friend started laughing about
it you know my even some people who i
really inspire
who i used to get inspired by them you
know some mentor
some like officers who are saying that
nymphs it's not possible
you know in order to go over there you
shouldn't be on the super fit you got to
have the knowledge like
brain of attainment i was like yeah
whatever man but then
i worked so hard because it was unknown
to me i came from landlord country and
then
nobody had ever made into sbs and and my
own training resign was
mental i had never trained like this in
my whole life brother i used to wake up
at one o'clock
i used to carry like 75 to 80 pounds on
my back
i used to tab which is a speed marks 20
kilometers
i used to be at the military camp by
like
seven o'clock then i do normal physical
training with my military guys for an
hour whatever that physical you know
pt is then i work whole day as a
as a labor because i was engineer and i
was you know building an instructor
finisher so he's styling his painting
it's plastering
and at the evening i used to again run
clean fatigue i
like i used to leave my bargain in this
school and i run back to the house
again 20 kilometers quick food then i go
to the gym i cycle 65 miles again
from nepal not a good swimmer then i
used to do freestyle like 100 lens in 25
meters full
and i used to literally finish about
like not before 10 o'clock
then i used to be again couple of hours
rest and then i'm doing that same thing
again and i never said
i'm tired i never said oh it's raining
today or is it snowing today i never
said that
it was you know like relentless often
hard work
what's the drive what was what was the
drive to keep you doing that
it's the love for the thing man it
wasn't never for money i didn't ever
want it to be like you know of course
when you join special forces you get
paid a lot you get so much facilities
you got so many access to that to the to
the other other stuff
and you are super respected as well in
the community but i never joined uk
special forces to be
a general or to make millions or to make
more money than anybody else it was just
i wanted to be part of that cool group
who earned their respect you know and
that's what the driving was comfort
it's for the love and of course if you
love something you got to commit you got
to
dedicate you've got to work 10 times
harder than anybody else out there
so yeah after serving 10 years with with
the special forces i was like okay
yeah what's next and then i got this
idea of climbing all the 14 highest
mountain and then
my purpose was again bigger than
where i am from who i am bigger than my
family bigger than anything else else it
was
it was for the human race and that's
what it kept me fired up brother and it
was like you know what money is nothing
you know we all
go one day we all die one day doesn't
matter how much you you make
doesn't matter how much money you you
have you're going to go as
you can so if you've got the purpose and
bigger stuff and you've got the
happiness
come on that's who i am buddy that's a
beautiful message man
i spoke to mutual friend of ours and
past modern wisdom guest jay morton
the other day and he gave me some inside
information on you
he told me that during special forces
selection in the jungle
you were nearly killed by a tree while
you were asleep
yeah it felt like yeah he said that
dead trees falling is like the number
one killer
of people in the jungle and this tree
fell
and your hammock there was a u-shaped
hole in the tree
that was the precise size of you and it
just happened to miss you
lucky bro you're blessed someone someone
out there is looking is looking after
you
one of the things again jase thank you
jay brother he sent me this big voice
note that really gave me some more
perspective especially about yourself
and um he said he doesn't think
most people realize just how difficult
of a feat
this is it's one of the most insane
physical accomplishments
ever but it's got nowhere near as much
press as it deserves that's that was
what jay said
do you think part of this is because
going up a mountain is so
alien to most people they don't really
understand how hard it is
for instance ross edgely swimming around
the uk
is another endurance feat that's
occurred recently
most people have swam at one point
they've done a couple of lengths in a
pool and then
if you were to say right now you need to
do six hours on six hours off
all day for 180 days people can
understand what that is
but altitude sickness and the
technical side of using crampons and
hooking in and climbing and all this
sort of stuff
doing rescues is that so far removed
from people's understanding that it's
it's almost like an
alien achievement i i think so buddy and
you are absolutely right
for fact it's not football you know
that's why you know
i'm not you know as uh as famous as you
know like in a messy
let's put it that way but what this
sport is
is super dangerous it's super risky it's
like
you live in a moment in any mistake you
make
you die that's it and there's no no
coming back to it that's why people are
scared of doing these things
it is a voluntary pain because i decided
to do this but then
every step that you take on the snow or
you're climbing you're like cough is
burning your lungs are on fire
and you feel like you're gasping for the
air
you know and then if you get that wrong
as well you might have an altitude
sickness which could be like you're
gonna have water in your lungs
you're gonna have you know like the
brain gonna swallow because there's a
fluid as well
and and there's no coming back from this
you just have to either evacuate it from
the mountains
or you die it's very simple and
and the sport is so extreme that it's
kind of an
alien that that's why people don't
understand it that's why i said like
when i said i was going to climb all
this 14 8 000 me to pick in seven months
most people didn't get it but then those
who got it
especially from the mountaineering world
brother at first when i said
when they saw me they were like oh there
you go 14
7. i can sense it they're like
it's good to say but do you even know
what it takes to climb 1000 meter peak
because those people knew it so those
people kind of knew the
the enormity of this the size of the
project but then for regular people
they didn't know what it was and then
hence why what sets you apart then
you've got these very experienced
mountaineers much more experienced than
you were when you started
and they're saying this is impossible
the previous record
was seven years as opposed to seven
months
what is it about you why why were you
able to do it
okay it's very simple brother you know
yes
i had a bit of talent you know like such
as like people like usain bolt people
like muhammad ali they have the natural
talent but then
i also worked maybe 20 times harder than
any other people in the world i say it
and every time and then and it wasn't
just like given to me brother
you know i climb in the wind speed of 75
kilometer per hour
people can't even dare to get out of
their house in like normal storm
forget that you are at the death zone
and you are like the
the wind is blasting your tent with the
snow and it's so cold
it's beyond people's imagination and
then you know what i haven't slept for
19 days in pakistan when i was
climbing this this peak because we had
to run everywhere to make it for the
for the best cam and then there's a
summit and
if you don't sleep for 24 hours you
imagine how you feel
and then that's you without doing
anything else you let's say you don't
even have a
thing to do if i'm burning my energy
like a ten man if i'm climbing in that
brutal conditions
if i'm climbing this this high altitude
mountains where people take two months
to climb
and i haven't slept why i did that
because i believed in my purpose i
believe in the vision
i was gonna show the world that nothing
is impossible and then i put
my name into it i put the reputation of
uk special forces into it
i put the reputation of gurkhas into it
and i put the reputation of you know
like nepalese columbus into it
at no point i honestly believe that i
had the rights to make mickey out of my
project because
i didn't do well and when you believe in
anything what you do
sometimes you might have to exaggerate
that but this is who i am
i feel like people have given their life
to to
to have that reputation people have work
so it wasn't my
reputation to damage it it was built
on layers there's hundreds of years by
those hard-working men
behind the scene to build that
reputation and who am i as an insider to
ruin that reputation
and i believe in that it could be wrong
but then i believe that you know i had
much more to give and i was showing the
world that you know what
do not let anybody tell you that you are
impossible coming from
as you asked chris earlier you said what
is the
the main story here the main story is
like you you can come from nowhere else
like me you don't need to have an
opportunity
like me you know you don't need to have
support like me
but then if you work hard enough if you
commit to it
if you dedicate into it even though
there will be negativity they will
challenge you turn that into positivity
you can achieve the success against all
the odds that is a very simple message
from all this stuff
and i hope anybody can relate their life
into this story because we all have our
own mountains to climb we all have our
own challenges
but how we overcome that challenge how
we become that person i believe that
the 8 billion population has got their
own talents
but you need to find out what your
talent is and if you love that
stuff and you work 10 times harder than
everybody else
you will be number one
you said that you were talented
what does talent mean when it comes to
mountaineering
is it so capacity in your lungs because
you had
you overcame was it tb and asthma
as like a kid yeah yeah so as someone
who's pre-asthmatic
to me doesn't strike me as the sort of
person that makes a fantastic mountain
era that goes above 8 000 meters
oh yeah brother you know like i believe
again you know that the power of
believing is is massive
your brain controls your body that's
very simple science
you know what you believe if you believe
in your brain that you can run 10
kilometers you can run 10 kilometers
but if you believe that you can just do
only one kilometer you do only one
kilometer
and it's the power of the brain body and
if i feel i can heal quicker
i will heal quicker because if you put
same patients in the hospital with
similar injuries
the person who believed that he can
overcome those injuries or whatever
it is will get healed better and now
coming into the capacity buddy
i wasn't even born at altitude i was
born in the most flattest part of nepal
you know
it's so hot even the flight dies at the
road man it's like super hot it's jet
one um but yeah somehow
you know i i kind of had this ability to
climatize well
and that's what pretty much all of this
you know people who live in high
altitude
have the similar ability but what it
makes me different is is the
decision-making ability the purpose why
i was doing this stuff
it wasn't just for nothing i i was on a
mission
i was on an objective i had a clear aim
i had a clear direction
that's why you know i became who i am
and and it's very simple
tell us the story about when you were
awake for all of those days
in pakistan it was crazy brother and at
some point where you feel like it's
your climbing like oh my god
i went so loud about this project
jesus you know like i cannot obviously
come back you know of course sometimes
you just feel like that pain is so hard
you feel like i wish that air lance
comes from that mountain and just kill
me it's index
and that kills all the pain but then you
think like no nymphs it's not about that
and then sometimes
because you haven't slept you know you
are literally like climbing and you feel
asleep and you are oh sh
said you know if you miss this one you
probably die then human body is kind of
you know like
doing this automatic stuff but then i
used to like oh my god no no no no
i used to grab the snow and rub in my
face put in my armpit and i was like ah
then
if that doesn't work for a bit then i
used to sound so loud on the mountain
like a madman
you know honestly i used to like you
know make noise and then
the noise is so loud that it works your
way but then you can do for so long
because you know you've got so much
energy to do that then again back to
your snow and back to you know like you
know your points why you are doing it
who are you all these you know
motivating factors
so you build them as you go and then
that's
that's something you need to have i
guess has it changed you
as a person no man i'm still
simple guy i'm still you know i respect
the nature
you know i still say you know i'm humble
but then you know we all have ego
brother we all have people
everybody as a human has ego but the
size of my ego depends upon who i talk
to
if they're respectful i'm respectful if
they want to come with the biggest
ego that they couldn't put their head
inside the door i'll kick them out
already because
i think i have done enough to do that
and that's not with me as well
anybody in the world nobody wants that
kind of in a person
to deal with we all have you know that
kind of stuff but it's all about how you
manage it
i would love to say and i want to stay
humble i respect those people who are
humble
but if people want to come with all this
stuff i don't have time for that brother
park it and
move on um can you explain what it's
like
going up the side of a mountain because
i've climbed up hills before
but that's just me one foot in front of
the other it's basically a path
on an incline and upon reading the book
there's all different manner of
uh teamwork that goes on with the person
in front who has to cut through snow and
there's different heights of snow can
you just take us through
what it's like to to go up the side of a
mountain
okay so i would like to speak about the
trailblazing here so trailblazing is
like you are the first man on that
snow you know and then during the
project we we break
we trail blaze on the snow conditions up
to like waist deep and chest deep
and what that means is like at some
point you've got to create a gap
and then you roll your hip and then you
sink in
and then you go and and it's so must
stop
because you need oxygen in your
muscles to operate when you have no
oxygen your lungs is like dying to
to support you know the air in your
muscles it's tough bro it's like
even grabbing like 10 depending upon who
you are
grabbing a day backpack of you know 10
kgs is like dragging a car at the sea
level
and if you have to trail blaze like that
every steps count and every breath
counts and
every second is as painful as probably i
can explain but then
for me why i do that maybe i say
i love that kind of funny stuff i love
when there's a challenge i
love it because you know it's something
that make me
come on you know it also made me feel
like i'm living in the moment i'm not
thinking about how much mortgages i have
to pay
i don't have to worry about what this is
going on what the world is doing i'm
just living in the moment saying
if i get this wrong i could probably die
because you know i
i don't have enough time to go back to
the summit and come back and sometimes
you are leading in a very technical
region where it's a blue ice
for example on k2 if you make a mistake
you die and then and the other point
here is
imagine you are sleeping in the tent at
the death journey
so cold that you know you're in the
sleeping bag it's warm
as soon as you leave that you've got
like snow coming into your face it's
like it's horrible
but then you have to wake up and it's so
cold that it takes half an hour to put
your boots sometimes
to get out of that comfort from the
sleeping bag at the middle of the night
and then get ready
that is the biggest mission as well so
it's it's so tough from all level
but as i said you know learning about
trailblazing
like the specifics about how you do it
you walk forward
you make a hole in waist high
snow yeah with your chest so you use
your belly i guess
it's like a a snow plow then
you use that extra bit of space you step
forward and then you do it again
so how slowly how slowly are you moving
oh my it depends upon who you are man
and sometimes people take
so long to climb you know all this in a
distance you know like for example if
there is
if the snow condition is perfect i
climbed the world highest
like well you know third highest
mountain in just 18 hours
but then for the world's seventh highest
mountain it took us five days
because it was so tough the wind
conditions the snow conditions
yeah but again you know like if you look
at the speed of you know my climbing
style i climbed
everest lots and more that's the world's
first fourth and fifth highest mountain
in 48 hours
people have never done like this and
then if you see how much it's taking me
to do that
you can imagine guys so yeah two days
to climb the first fourth and fifth
highest mountains
all of them back to back all of them
back to back
what the [ __ ] man
i don't even know what to say about that
like
it's the the main thing
i think that it would appear is the
other than the physical fatigue but some
people there's ultra endurance athletes
out there
who might be able to deal with that
level of fatigue but it's the
um altitude changes that would end
most people right yeah it's it's the
altitude but you know you could be you
know like more pharah or you said bull
at sea level that means nothing over
there brother and then that's why i said
you know like
it's a completely different game and you
know people think just because you are
from special forces you can
do no not really i have climbed with so
many special forces and then
and they are like wow names how the hell
you do this you know you're not only
trailblazing and you don't
just like leave us like so far behind
but then you come up you go down and
we haven't even recovered for like two
months since we're climbing with you
so and then there are so many other
people and i think but for me
yes i have got a bit of you know like i
would say
a bit of like natural talent that means
of course i can climatize a bit
a bit better but then for me i love that
when you love so much that this next
level mate
if you have if you like if you're a
football player or if you love that
football so much
you will not realize you know if you
have run a marathon in in process of
changing the ball or whatever it is but
if you make that football or wherever it
is
to run full marathon he's gonna regret
it he's gonna be like oh my god it's so
tough because
that's he doesn't love doing marathon he
loves playing football
so it's all about how much passion you
have got for that sport
and that's what it makes the difference
so the simple message again here in life
guys if you are doing something that you
don't love
you should change it going out those
days that you have to have one job in
your life
you know the world is changing adapt to
it you know try something new and if you
like that you could be the
the number one in that so there's a
quote and it's one life
a quote that i absolutely love by naval
ravikant and it says
become the best in the world at what you
do keep redefining what you do
until this is true and that's what
you're saying exactly
keep on redefining what it is that you
do until you can be
one of the best people on the planet at
it but you you're very very humble about
the
the um work ethic that you have
but i would absolutely love for a sport
scientist to get a hold
of your physiology and look at
what your lung capacity is what your red
blood cell count is what your vo2 max is
your lactate threshold all of this stuff
because as much as hard work can take
you to this place
the there has to be some special source
that's somewhere inside of you the same
as elliot kipchoge
we can say that this guy trains as hard
he lives this
he's like a monk lives this monastic
lifestyle way
he's very very simple man but there is
something
special in his physiology that permits
him to do that and i want to get if
there's any sports scientists listening
please just grab a hold of nims and give
us some samples of his muscle fiber and
take some bloods from him because i want
to know
i want to know what the hell is
happening inside of your body man
we see we find out that would be cool
talk to us about that everest photo
all right paul this you know i it was
used in a wrong reason
it was used misutilized by the media
people
and some of them didn't even give the
credit and and i'm super
upset i will tell you the the exact
thing because i have been there this is
this is my world you know
every year 20 000 people climb one block
is the highest mountain in europe
more than 20 000 people and then
if you try to capture the few people of
like 20 000 people how how much q you're
gonna
see on montblanc well unlike mount
everest montblanc has got so many
different opportunities it has got
different
weather conditions and there are so many
like you know
i would say um opportunities of getting
to the summit at different time interval
and it's not a thousand meters only you
know like thousand but everest
only like 1200 per minute where you sit
and that number is
relatively low it wasn't any bigger than
2014 2013 11 or anything else
and a lot of people were commenting
about this without
knowing about everest you know they were
like oh it's a tourist and all it's like
no
it's not you know you got to go into the
mountain you go to accommodate for
almost two months
you got to come through this kombu ice
fall that can kill you at
any time then forget the lots of wall
it's like 1.6
miles you know and it's about 55 degrees
you got to climb that then into the
south coal then you got to climb the
everest
have you done that if you haven't then
please
don't comment now coming into the
picture
a lot of this kind of people were over
there and that season
because of the whole weather condition
there was only one good day towards the
end of the season
and of course if you have put your time
effort money
some people have sold their house you
want to go for that you want to take
that opportunity
so everybody took that opportunity it's
a it's a human thing
and don't say that oh it's a tourist no
man you know if you haven't
been there and if you haven't done that
you know yeah
and then that's what it offset me
because you know people use it for the
wrong reason
you know if you have crime everest in in
whatever way
then you can talk but then again be true
to yourself
you know and then a lot of people ask me
oh everest is a lot easier and it's like
no
really man because i spoke with reinhold
messner who climbed all this in a
thousands without oxygen
if you remove all the support manpower
the the the therapist and everybody else
everest is still the hardest mountain to
climb you cannot even go through the
kumbaya so i'll forget in a lots of wall
so if you don't know enough knowledge
don't talk about it guys that's all i
want to say
it was interesting that that's your
viewpoint on it and that's the reason
i mean why did you take the photo for
that reason just because it was
interesting and impressive
no no no no i took the reason because i
was trying to climb everest and let's
say
in just six hours my previous record was
10 hours 15 minutes
which i had broken accidentally i didn't
even knew that i was just like going in
my normal place
so when i said i was gonna break my
world record by like you know let's say
almost half because at this point i'm
conscious
so but then i got stuck in the traffic
and all that
somebody yes i'm i'm a man of my word
and if somebody questioned me like okay
you said that but you didn't do it
people are always like that man you will
find people like this and i'll say okay
it's good you send me that but then this
is the reason i it was just for my
evidence
i understand you made this like negative
haters shot their mouth but then
it was used in other purpose brother but
hey man that's so
interesting that in your opinion is
someone who's more qualified than pretty
much everybody on the planet to talk
about going up and down mountains
quickly
you're still saying everest's the
hardest mountain to climb on the planet
if it's unsupported
it's still even supported incredibly
difficult
the reason that the mountain on that day
was so heavily populated is because
of the backlog of people you get when
they do a push to base camp one base
camp two and then they finally go
up and down in a day you only had a
short window of weather
and then yeah yeah it gets flipped
because the message that came across to
me
as a normal member of the public was
look at
these rich lazy
adventure wannabes who are paying
probably cheap local
sherpas to carry all of their stuff up
you know what it reminded me of
this is what i thought when i first saw
all of the news stories have you seen
those images
of people who've shot lions in
um parks in africa and stuff like that
and there's always
it's always a rich american businessman
he's a bit fat he's sweating
and yeah you've got this this kind of
fat
picture of modern day excess
human next to a really proud gracious
animal
that someone else is tracked and he's
killed and it gave me the same sensation
as that
it made me think have we commodified
have we made so commercialized
the tallest supposedly most difficult
mountain on the planet
and what you're saying is that it's
quite the opposite it's
still incredibly hard to do and
for anyone that actually understands the
way that you do a push up the mountain
this queue of people was inevitable
because they'd done the hard work and
this was their one opportunity to get to
the there was one opportunity and then
who wouldn't take that you know so if
you don't
if you haven't done that and if you
haven't been there and you could have
done you know
yeah some people even commented because
they climb in in different air at
different times it's
still the same if at that point when
these people had climbed
and there was there were other climbers
off to this enormous size because
of the of the education because of the
knowledge that people knew that then
you would still be in that same position
it's just the time you know it's
changing because now people know what it
is and people know what it takes
just because you have been there for the
first time doesn't mean like
it was so like hard still you get to
climb that mountain
either somebody run to like full
marathon in two hours or whatever it is
you still have to run that marathon
still you have to do it you cannot just
say
oh one person did full marathon and he's
the first man to do it
or negative brother if people are still
doing full medicine now
still you got to claim that achievement
because you run that same distance
be broad about the thinking people and
uh
let's stop being so like
i don't know you know people just always
pointing this one and like
judgmental negative energy yeah you know
we have come into this world where
this is a time to adjust this is the
time where i feel like
it's not about the race it's not about
you know which national you are from
it's not about
now this thing's going to change it's
about the human rights and and now
coming into this my topic
this is going to happen because with the
climate change with the global warming
if we all as a human being don't work
together
we're not gonna extinct we just we're
just gonna disappear
so this is where you know the things are
happening naturally brother you know
like where you know it's not about you
know
before it was if you see the world again
back and then people were like about
the rest people were from that is
changing now slowly and then now we are
changing for a reason
we are changing for for our survival as
well
so in every areas that we need to be
broader thinking in a human i guess
was there not a story associated with
your photo
to do with people leaving rubbish on the
mountain
no it wasn't thank god okay but do you
know
do you know what i'm talking about i've
i just made this yeah
no no so i think you know there are a
lot of you know rubbish and stuff on on
the big mountains and all and
you know sometimes you know people are
so tired and they don't do it but then
i think now you know or also some people
probably didn't knew the extremity of of
that
that that incident and that probably
didn't know how much it's going to
affect
the world by leaving a trust there but
now everybody is getting educated
you know people probably you know used
to leave the electricity on in the house
even
if they are not there but now people are
getting educated so if they turn the
electricity off they don't do food waste
you know at least some people are trying
and then it's exactly the same i think
that the education has
the awareness has gone a bit wider now
and of course all these people love that
love the mountains and and
as we progress towards this in the next
generation
everybody will start cleaning this up
and i think
nobody is there as a bad human i would
say and it's just about
the perspective we all want to do the
good in life
i don't think anybody in the world want
to be known for like super bad in the
man i don't know
if there is this maybe point whatever
percent but
everybody wants to be happy everybody
wants to be a good person
so i think we are a good person so i
think we will start cleaning all that up
in the in the future all my expedition
that we run we're gonna
if there's there's a capacity with with
our guides and all we'll bring it down
and uh and it's not like the effort of
one person
we all have to do together and as long
as everybody
put everything what they do as
as a core messes are you like we have to
look after our earth in whatever
way we do then then it's fair
and then and i think the whole thing
with um i just recently was you know sir
david
attenborough you know you know you know
the witness is in a
statement and it's very simple you know
we don't have to be super like you know
like
you know wrong or super like you know
like i don't know
extreme about this but as long as it's
practical and as long as we
whatever decision we make we put you
know our home as an
earth as a core into that decision
making that we are making
will make the whole difference and and
that could be
small from like people like us to the
politicians to the billionaires
everybody if everybody plays their part
we're smiling so what
what did you see in terms of climate
change
what effects can you see on the mountain
so from my own eyes i was on amazon in
2014
at that point when we were at someone
you know we could
melt the snow and we can cook our food
and drink
i went there again in 2018 and then
you know what there was no snow anything
else and we had to carry like 20 liters
of water from the base camp
and 20 liters is 20 kg and when you had
to carry that
of that altitude just because you know
the global warming is happening and all
that
it kicks you man then the other incident
was i was in dallas
so the allegory is known as the white
mountain because it snows
all the time it's the world's seventh
highest mountain
i was there in 2014 and last year when i
went you know during the
the bremen project possible the whole
glacier was like melting and and i
saw it from my own eyes and that was a
bit
really sad moment brother and hence why
you know like last year i said i was
going to raise the awareness about
climate change but now
as a name style as a person i'm acting
on it you know i cannot change the world
but then i can change in my
lifestyle i can do whatever i can do in
order to like you know
be more sustainable
you didn't number yourself or something
you did a number of unplanned rescues as
well didn't you
yeah can you take us through some of
them
yeah so a lot of people again criticize
once you do it oh yeah
he climbed with oxygen and all first of
all if you want to say that buddy
go and try with oxygen or without oxygen
and you once you do it you can talk if
you haven't done it
again park your ideas okay but there is
a reason why i climb with oxygen from
campfire i only take
oxygen from the highest scam okay before
that i didn't take it and that comes
into the story in 2016
when i was climbing everest you know in
my holiday between you know war tours to
afghanistan and all that nobody knew
about it
when i rescued a climber from 8450
meters
alone and and that 500 meter worth of
rescue it takes probably some
it takes half a day depending upon where
it could even take a full day
i did that rescue in 90 minutes and when
i brought her to camphor i handed to the
rescue team
and it took two days for the rescue of
five people
to bring her to camp to then i realized
wow
i can if i go this oxygen i can save
someone's life like that
coming from a special forces background
whatever we do in misun we always have a
debrief what went well
what went wrong and what are the lessons
learned and the lesson
learned from for me that everest
expedition was
climbing all this mountain even though i
wanted to eventually climb without
oxygen
it wasn't about ego it wasn't about
proving that
and then yeah and then i was like okay
if i can save someone's life i'll do it
now coming into this project you know i
guess i had this man with project in
front of me
for which i had sacrificed my job for
which i have given up my pens and
everything
the first rescue got called up in
annapurna we're meant to be going on
dalagiri our second mountain
but i was like you know what for me i
have never left anyone behind him in war
either i shopped with the guy cause or
espresso forces and
that's not gonna happen on the mountain
so i abandoned this
how like remission we went with our team
and uh
so what happens someone rings someone
rings you i mean who calls
no no he was missing then there was a
helicopter you know that
and who looked for you know mr chin like
dr chin
his wife was you know paying for the
helicopter to go and then search it
they found that he was alive then we're
every details in
in the book brother but if i go into
this one i think it's going to be so
so in-depth conversation i don't think
we have time for that but then
moving into another rescue so we did
that rescue
we saved his life but then we're seeing
enough because we missed the complete
weather conditions
you know all our team were destroyed our
lines were gone
and then we had to climb in this brutal
condition which it took us five days
i could have probably done that in a day
but then again you know
going into now kanchanjanga was the
world's highest mountain
we rescued four people and this is
very important message here brother at
eight thousand four hundred fifty meters
we found a climber whose oxygen was
running out
okay then we gave our oxygen to him so
he's straight away he's alive
we started risking him down then we got
another climber
he also ran out of his oxygen so we gave
our oxygen so we are off oxygen now
conducting the rescue from 8450 meters
without oxygen
when you are not climatized i said when
you are not climatized
it's a suicidal mission but we knew what
our body was capable of and all that so
again you know all this rescue stuff you
know for me it comes because
i want to sleep peacefully when i go to
bed brother you know i don't want to say
that okay you know i left this in a
manner you know you know female or
fellow climbers behind when i had the
ability to
do the rescue yeah of course you know my
project is important but then
you know life is important than that
brother so
yeah but that's who i am and again you
know if you're listening to this story
guys and if you want to
you know know in-depth knowledge you
know why i do things and
and and and why i am who i am and all
there is in depth story on on my book
beyond possible
so yeah feel free to dig in that'll be
linked in the show notes below man don't
worry we will be pushing everybody into
that as well
what's next for you
well i'm preparing for k2 winter
expedition so k2 is the only
mountain in the world it's the second
highest mountain in the world
that has never been on climb in winter
so all other 8000 meter peak
have been have been climbed in winter
this is the last greatest
i don't know whatever the feet you say
it so yeah i'm out there buddy i'm out
there
this christmas uh and new year to go and
do this
i'm still working on a sponsorship and
hopefully
you know that will pull through and uh i
can go and do this again in another
impossible stuff
so yeah so that's this year climbing the
second highest mountain in the world
in the worst conditions possible yeah
and no one is ever climbing the k2 in
winter so yeah
what is it that's going to make that
difficult wind speeds temperature
ice what is this oh you're going to get
you know hurricane winds
it's going to be -65 in the celsius and
then it's going to be
it's going to be so cold you know you
yeah it's going to be born cold
you know but yeah we see man we see how
you know like
um you know how how we get on over there
and at the end of the day the nature has
you know bigger things to say
uh still you know we are positive we
have got the right attitude
we got the speed uh but again you know
sometimes you know just being the best
is not enough for this kind of you know
like fit
um no one can defeat the nature we only
get the passes if you got the passes
we'll do it if
we don't get it and it's beyond our like
in a capabilities or whatever it is due
to the weather conditions
you've got to stay humble man
i i absolutely love it today's been
fantastic uh people want to check out
more to do with you where should they go
um
i am available i think most of my stuff
are you know updated and in in tune on
my instagram
uh at nymsty so yeah and also you know
like for k2 and all
once we we properly announced it which i
haven't announced because of the
sponsorship stuff at the moment
and if if that deal comes through i'm
going to announce it we'll have a
website page and all that but yeah just
just in instagram at the moment perfect
beyond possible will be linked in the
show notes below as well go and check it
out it's a really fantastic read
and you get to go into all of the
details that we didn't have time for
today
man i uh i don't know i feel like i want
to go and climb up the side of a
building or
go and go and do something crazy now um
i think that you're a wonderful
ambassador man it seems like you're very
aligned with
what it is that you want in terms of
purpose with trying to
live in um synchronicity with the world
i i think that the next few years are
going to have wonderful things so
make sure that you get back from k2 in
one piece max i think that we need more
people like you
thank you my man and and that means a
lot to me brother thank you
[Music]